Welcome, students,
to our continuation
on the pharmacology
of anti
-seizure drugs. Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
In this part of the
lecture, we will
describe the broad
spectrum anti
-seizure drugs and
other molecular
targets and the drugs
that act on them.
Our learning objectives,
always important.
Pharmacokinetics,
mechanisms,
mechanisms, mechanisms.
You should be able
to recognize which
drugs are being used,
just as a general
statement, for focal
seizures versus
primary generalized
onset seizures.
star drugs of course
we talked about
polymorphisms in the first
part we'll mention at
one time in this section
and thinking about
all of the different
pharmacology features
of the drugs for
the selection of the
appropriate therapy for
the individual patient
materials and links
if you wish to use
them. We'll begin with
our broad spectrum
anti-seizure drugs,
valproate and
topiramate. Divalpro
-X is also valproate.
I'm not going to talk
about zanisamide.
The pharmacology
of zanisamide is
pretty comparable to
other anti-seizure
drugs such as
topiramate and you can
pick it up later
on if you need to.
Beginning with valproate.
The structure is
important in terms of
the pharmacokinetics
of the drug and some
adverse effects. We
see it's just this
small fatty acid and
as a fatty acid it
undergoes mitochondrial
beta-oxidation.
Also, glucuronide
conjugation, which is
going to make it water
-soluble. And there
are certainly other
pathways involved with
the metabolism
of L-proate. Good
bioavailability. Now,
going back to the top,
it's given ****** or
IV, very convenient.
pretty high protein
binding which is saturable
and that's going to
depend on the dose
the higher the dose
the greater the risk of
saturation the greater
the probability of
saturation and hence the
greater the free drug.
Half-life varies So
between this feature
and this feature,
it's very important
to be monitoring
blood levels in the
individual patient to
make sure that it's
right there in the
therapeutic range.
As a broad-spectrum
drug, it has
multiple cellular
mechanisms that
have been observed
in model systems.
As I have mentioned
before, with all
of these drugs, the
actual mechanisms in
human beings, in
mammalian patients,
hasn't been empirically
demonstrated. These
are effects that
are seen in animal
models, in laboratory
models, and then it's
been extrapolated to
say these may be the
actions of anti-seizure
effect in people.
The takeaway here
is broad spectrum,
multiple cellular
mechanisms.
So, with valproate,
we see blocking of
the sodium currents,
voltage-dependent
sodium currents. We
see reductions in the
voltage-dependent T
-type calcium currents.
And here you will
become familiar that
when you see T-type
calcium currents,
you're going to be
thinking absence,
as it's pronounced
in French,
absence in
English, seizures.
And increasing
in GABA will,
at least theoretically,
increase the effects of
GABA, which
are inhibitory.
well proate is
a first line
agent this is a
very important
drug in the anti
-seizure drug
armamentarium it can
be used alone it can
be used as adjunct
adjunct means in
combination with other
anti-seizure drugs.
And it treats a
variety of different
types of seizure,
both focal
onset, primary
generalized onset,
refractory seizures,
and status epilepticus.
It's actually
used off-label
for status epilepticus,
but it's effective non
-seizure applications
also it is used for
the management of acute
mania in patients who
have bipolar disorder
and it can be used
for the prevention of
migraine prevention is
better than treatment
always with migraine
and what's our takeaway
Valproate is useful
for many seizure
types and it has non
-seizure applications
because of its
multiple mechanisms
and broad spectrum
of activity.
Boy, it has quite a
list of adverse effects,
doesn't it? And this
is not complete.
We would expect
the CNS effects,
of course. All
anti-seizure drugs
have CNS effects and
CNS side effects,
therapeutic and
side effects.
Sedation, dizziness,
ataxia, cognitive
impairment. This
looks a little
bit like taking too
much alcohol in.
these GI effects with
valproate can really
make it difficult for
the patient to tolerate
it and remember many
children have seizure
disorder and will be
taking valproate nausea
vomiting on top of
that the heart bank
heartburn and just plain
ordinary abdominal pain
So in order to improve
tolerance, it's
suggested to start low
and gradually titrate
the dose upward.
Start low, go slow.
And that may help, but
another thing
to do is food.
Also, formulations.
There are
different formulations
of valproate
that can at least
reduce the abdominal
side effects
to some extent.
Tremor.
Patients who take
valproate can
develop this fine
tremor, and it's
noticeable. Hair
loss, weight gain,
hepatotoxicity,
thrombocytopenia, and
reduced platelet
function.
Ammonia. This is ammonia
here. Blood ammonia.
Hyperammonemia.
Too much ammonia in
the blood. When it gets
into the brain in high
enough concentrations,
it can actually cause
an encephalopathy.
And this effect,
go back now to the
fact that valproate
is metabolized in
the mitochondria.
It can inhibit the
enzyme that's
necessary for ammonia
elimination through
the urea cycle.
So this, of
course, would be a
concentration-related
effect. The higher
the dose, the
higher the risk.
Pancreatitis can
occur. it's quite rare
fortunately but we
remain alert and look
for it hypersensitivity
reactions i'm
sure you've noticed
this is a running theme
with pretty much
all of these anti
-seizure drugs we've
seen up to this point
rash stevens johnson
syndrome toxic epidermal
necrolysis drug
reaction with
eosinophilia and systemic
symptoms, and that
can be fatal. All of
these can be fatal.
Caution. So now
here we have a
polymorphism to talk
about, and it's related
to this mitochondrial
DNA polymerase
gamma. That's the
particular type of
polymerase within
the mitochondria.
Of course it has
an acronym P-O-L-G.
So mutations in the gene
that express
this polymerase
put patients at
increased risk for
this liver failure
and death naturally.
If a patient has this
valproate is
contraindicated.
Valproate is teratogenic.
It causes neural tube
defects, craniofacial
defects, cardiovascular
malformations,
other malformations,
and this is not a
teratogenic effect, but
there is an increased
risk of lower IQs and
neurodevelopmental
defects in the children
of people who have
been taking valproate
during pregnancy.
So, therefore,
the drug is
contraindicated for
non-seizure uses,
all non-seizure
uses in
individuals who are
pregnant or may
become pregnant.
And regarding
seizure disorder, if
valproate can be
changed prior to
pregnancy, then that
would be desirable.
Drug interactions,
it's an inhibitor
of the metabolism
of many drugs.
and specifically,
we want to remember
lamotrigine.
Lamotrigine has
been found to have
an increased risk
of these skin
reactions, these
serious skin reactions
due to this HLA
-B polymorphism.
So lamotrigine, even
given as monotherapy,
must be gradually,
carefully titrated up to
the therapeutic dose.
When it's given together
with valproate, that
process needs to be
even slower because
of this inhibitory
effect of valproate on
lamotrigine metabolism.
moving to topiramate
now i give you the
structures but you
don't have to remember
them this is not as
important as remembering
the valproate structure
you don't have
to actually draw out
valproate structure
you just remember it's
a little fatty acid
with topiramate
it's got a favorable
pharmacokinetic profile
good absorption good
bioavailability low
plasma protein binding.
Minor hepatic
metabolism that does not
use CYPs, a large
percentage of it is
excreted in the
urine, and it might
actually be reabsorbed
in the nephron.
Again, we see a number
of mechanisms therefore
multiple mechanisms
what are we thinking
broad spectrum i did
mention that in the
beginning i'll mention
it again multiple
mechanisms broad
spectrum it's been found
that it will inhibit
the voltage dependent
sodium current it also
depresses glutamate
activity through
blocking ampokinate
receptors. It enhances
GABA-A inhibitory
effect, and it has
carbonic anhydrase
inhibition. Now,
is this part of its
anti-seizure activity?
That's not known.
Carbonic anhydrase
inhibitors, given alone,
are known to have
some weak anti-seizure
activity. This is
relevant because of
toxicity. That's why
I'm bringing it up.
I'll get to that
when I get to the
toxicities. For now,
let's talk about the
therapeutic uses
adults and children.
As a broad spectrum
anti-seizure drug,
it is good for focal
onset seizures,
generalized onset
seizures, difficult-to
-treat seizures. Lennox
-Gastaut syndrome
is a seizure disorder
with onset in
childhood and it may
be effective in other
childhood seizure
types, time will tell.
Topiramate also has
several non-seizure
applications. Here we
see migraine again.
Prophylaxis of
migraine, prophylaxis of
cluster headaches. It
causes weight loss. That's
been observed as one
of its side effects.
So a drug company put
it together in the
same dosage form,
fixed combination, with
this amphetamine
-like sympathomimetic.
the topiramate has
also been used for
binge eating
disorder alcohol use
disorder and there
are others as well
adverse effects the cns
effects are quite common
we see the sleepiness
the tiredness
dizziness the
the slow thinking
paresthesias,
nervousness,
moodiness, confusion.
I did mention the
weight loss before.
Now, carbonic
anhydrase inhibition in
relation to the
toxicities of topiramate.
And children are the
most vulnerable, as
we hear over and
over with many drugs.
Carbonic anhydrase
inhibition, well, let
me just say the
carbonic anhydrase
inhibitors were
originally developed for,
as a diuretic,
it's a very weak
diuretic, so it's
not used for that.
They do act within
the nephron.
They act in the kidney.
And one of the things
they do in the kidney
is to decrease
serum bicarbonate by
increasing excretion of
bicarbonate. And that
That can lead to a mild
metabolic acidosis.
Children, as I mentioned
before and will
mention again, are
at the greatest risk.
Carbonic anhydrase
is very, very
important in many,
many, many functions
of the body,
including in the bone.
So bone loss has been
seen in children,
and that leads to
reduced growth.
importantly it can
reduce the ability
to sweat and sweating
is our one of our
air conditioning
mechanisms it helps us
to manage heat
and if sweating is
reduced that can lead
to hyperthermia when
are we thinking about
this when the child
or the individual
anybody taking topiramate
is in a warm a very
warm environment
so what are warm
environments well the first
thing we think about
is being out in the
hot sun or being in a
very very very warm room
those sort of things
being overdressed in
uh so that the child
is becomes overheated
and kidney stones this
can happen in anybody,
this increased risk
of kidney stones. It
doesn't happen too
often, very low
incidence, and it
certainly can happen when
carbonic anhydrase
inhibitors are used
alone. It's just
one of the potential
effects of carbonic
anhydrase inhibition.
Pregnancy. Adverse
effects have been
reported in animal
reproduction studies.
um so should we use them
in the pregnant
individual
well sometimes we
can't change a person's
anti-seizure therapy
it's just too
dangerous so the
pregnant woman should
be monitored pregnant
person should
be monitored for a
metabolic acidosis.
Newborns should be
monitored for that.
It should be avoided
in patients who are
taking topiramate for
the non-seizure uses.
It should be switched
if possible for
individuals who are
wishing to become pregnant.
Drug interactions.
Well, as you would
expect, enzyme
inducers increase
the clearance
of practically
everything.
Concurrent use of
topiramate and valproic
acid may increase the
risk of hyperammonemia.
What do we think
about with too much
ammonia in the
bloodstream? We think about
encephalopathy. And
of course it's a CNS
depressant. We saw
that with the adverse
effects and other
drugs that are CNS
depressants are going
to increase that effect.
So here are a
few very simple
little questions
for review.
Thinking of
valproate's mechanisms,
therapeutic uses, and
side effects, what are
three takeaways
regarding valproate? At
this point I invite
you to pause the video
and think about these
three questions.
See if you can come
up with the answers.
Certainly go back into
the PowerPoint and look
for the answers.
They're right in there.
So I will continue now.
The answer to the
first one, Valproate's
mechanisms, uses,
and side effects.
Valproate has multiple
mechanisms of action.
Valproate is a broad
-spectrum anti-seizure
drug and first-line
therapy in a range
of seizure types in
adults and children,
and it has non
-seizure applications.
Belproate has numerous
and common GI and
CNS side effects,
causes tremor and hair
loss and weight gain.
It can cause decreased
platelet function,
thrombocytopenia,
hyperammonemia,
hepatotoxicity,
hypersensitivity reactions.
Now, thinking of
topiramate's mechanisms,
therapeutic uses, and
side effects, What
are three takeaways
regarding topiramate?
Well, it has multiple
mechanisms of
action. It is a
broad-spectrum anti
-seizure drug and
used in a range of
seizure types for
adults and children.
So that's one
concept there,
broad-spectrum,
variety of seizure
types, common to
both topiramate and
valproate. Belproate
is first line.
Topiramate, not
necessarily first line.
Topiramate has
numerous and
common CNS side effects.
It's a weak
carbonic anhydrase
inhibitor, and it
can cause decreased
sweating and
hyperthermia in children,
reduced growth,
metabolic acidosis,
and possibly kidney
stones in anybody.
Well, what about
usage in pregnancy or
individuals who may
become pregnant?
So let's move on
now to the anti
-seizure drugs
that interact with
other types of
molecular targets.
And we will begin
with Felbamate.
this is the broad
spectrum anti-seizure
drug the mechanisms that
have been identified
the one of the main
one is that it's an
nmda receptor blocker
the nmda receptor is
a type of glutamate
excitatory receptor.
I have circled the NMDA
receptor on the post
-synaptic membrane
right here so we can
see NMDA receptor and
ions moving through.
So that gets blocked
by felbomate.
Excellent
bioavailability,
CYP3A4 metabolism,
long half-life in
adults. Remember in
kids, Half-lives
can be different, so
it's always important
to look up the
half-lives in the
drug monographs and
certainly to monitor
the drug levels.
So, NMDA glutamate
receptor blocker. This
is a use-dependent
block, meaning the NMDA
glutamate receptors
that are activated.
I'm not going into
more details than
that at this
point. And it might
be potentiating
GABA-A inhibition.
Oh, that's a
mistake. It might be
potentiating GABA-A
-mediated activity.
You know what? Let's
back up. It might be
potentiating GABA-A
-mediated inhibitory
actions. That's what I
meant to put on here,
inhibitory actions.
Seizure disorders
refractory to other anti
-seizure drugs. Okay,
we don't use felbomate
until other drugs
are not producing
the anti-seizure
outcomes that are needed.
and informed
consent must be
obtained. So we say
to ourselves, uh
-oh, what's going
on with this drug?
It's been found
with the use of this
drug, there are
high rates of fatal
aplastic anemia
and hepatitis and
hepatic failure
compared with those
treated with other
anti-seizure drugs.
It's used for these
very difficult
-to-treat Lennox
-Gastaut syndrome
seizures, focal onset
seizures, with or
without generalization,
but I really
do want to emphasize
refractory.
Some other side
effects, GI, CNS, drug
interaction, CYP3A4, CNS
depressants, pretty much
what we see with other
anti-seizure drugs.
Now
we're going
to look at the
gabapentinoids
and gabapentin. In
particular, this
is the prototype.
The other one in
the group pregabalin
is pretty much the
same as gabapentin.
If you know one,
you know the other.
This is a really little
molecule. It's
an amino acid.
So it's real
simple to remember.
I've indicated
over here the point
at which it acts.
This is a presynaptic
voltage-gated
calcium channel.
And I'll get into
the details of the
mechanism when I get
there. But see if you can
visualize where this
is on the presynaptic
neuron. Remember, the
presynaptic calcium
channels, when an
action potential comes
down, triggers its
opening, calcium flows
in, and the vesicles
then move down to
the plasma membrane,
and the neurotransmitter
becomes exocytosed
into the synapse.
So we have our gabapentin
pregabalin binding there.
starting with the
pharmacokinetics well
it's an amino acid
so it's taken up
by amino acid transporter
which of course
being a transporter
is saturable it
is not metabolized
it's excreted through
the kidney 100%
unchanged it's got
more non-seizure uses
than seizure uses
the seizure uses i
see i didn't put oh
here right here focal
onset seizure only add
-ons it's it's not it
doesn't work as well
for monotherapy and
a whole slew of non
-seizure uses but
neuropathic pain is right
there at the top of
the list restless
leg syndrome hot flashes
due to menopause,
diapetic neuropathy,
fibromyalgia.
So you can see these are
related to
neuropathic pain.
It's even been
used in general and
social anxiety
disorder, and on we go.
Looking at the
pharmacokinetics,
there are no known
metabolic interactions.
You see how those
two connect.
Pregnancy, adverse
events have been
observed in animal
reproduction studies.
And we don't have
a lot of data
for the use of
the gabapentinoids
in pregnant individuals.
So adverse effects,
sedation, and the higher
the dose, the more
likely these CNS
effects, dizziness. It
can also cause weight
gain and peripheral
edema. Here's an FDA
warning, respiratory
depression, and that can
be increased together
with other drugs that
cause respiratory
depression, like opioids,
some CNS depressants,
and in individuals
who are at risk.
Now,
rivaracetam. I
don't have a star on
that one. It's
basically the same
pharmacology as
levotiracetam. This is
something called
an SV2A synaptic
vesicle protein
inhibitor. I've got the
circle here.
This acts presynaptically.
We see the SV2A
receptor there on
the vesicle. and by
inhibiting that, it
inhibits the docking to
the plasma membrane,
which will in turn
inhibit release of
the neurotransmitter.
SVE2A appears to
reduce the synaptic
release of
glutamate and gamma.
Pharmacokinetics.
This, again, has
really attractive
pharmacokinetic
profile. oral, 100
% bioavailability.
It also can be
given intravenously.
Non-hempatic hydrolysis.
It goes out in the
urine as unchanged
drug, and it's got
an okay half-life.
It does require two
times a day dosing.
Broad spectrum.
So, it's got several
anti-seizure uses.
now here we go this
way you haven't seen
before the it's really
got an attractive side
effect profile in
relation to the other anti
-seizure drugs at least
mild to moderate uh
sometimes they even
subside some patients do
complain about the
fatigue and and the the
crankiness sleepiness
dizziness they do complain
about the cns effects
and it's been observed
to cause psychotic
symptoms as well but
low potential for
drug interactions
so levotiracetam
is used quite
frequently simply
because one it's broad
spectrum and
effective and it's got
these attractive
pharmacokinetic
properties and side
effect profile.
And now suppressors
of the T-type calcium
occurrence,
ethosuximide. We talked
about valproate. I put
it back here so you
remember to associate
valproate with
suppressing the T
-type calcium currents.
Ethosuximide, however,
is narrow spectrum.
it appears that this is
ethylsuximide's
only action.
Here is ethylsuximide
structure.
You don't have
to remember that.
Pharmacokinetics, oral,
CYP3A4 metabolism.
So we have to remember
about drug interactions.
Renal excretion of
metabolites, but not
much unchanged drug.
it's got a really long
half-life even in
children but I'm going
to come back to that
in a minute we'll
talk about mechanism
after this absence
seizures that's it
that's the only thing
nausea vomiting so
what what what can we
do food sleepiness
can disturb the sleep
and this is a drug
that's frequently given
to children because
it's children that
most commonly have
the absinthe seizures.
So, as happens
with a lot of CNS
depressants, it can
have that paradoxical
effect in children
and actually cause
hyperactivity.
What's the mechanism?
That hasn't been
figured out yet.
The good thing
is ethyl suxamide
does not inhibit
or induce other
CYPs or other
metabolic enzymes.
Now, long half-life,
but it still might be
given two to three times
a day. So what does
that mean? The 24-hour
dose would be divided
into two or three
times a day, and the
whole point is to reduce
the GI side effects
by giving a smaller
dose more frequently.
Mechanism.
Ethosuximide reduces the
low-threshold calcium
currents, these are
called T-type calcium
currents, and the
thalamocortical neurons.
They have a picture
here of ethosuximide
binding site on the
calcium channel.
So what does this
do? By reducing these
calcium currents,
it suppresses the
paroxysmal 3 Hz spike
and wave pattern
that's typical of
absence seizures.
And I've defined what
3 Hz means here. The
waveform repeats three
times in one second.
And we have a
picture of an EEG
where we have the
spike and wave
typical of
absence seizures.
so let's have
some questions
I invite you to
pause your video
and think about the oh I
didn't cover the
answers amazing
I'll cover them now
so
I'm sure you
can pause the
computer and see
them but do try
and think about
them without
looking at the
answers, or go back in
the PowerPoint and
look at the answers.
So a particular
broad-spectrum anti
-seizure drug that
inhibits NMDA and
potentiates GABA
at GABA-8 receptors
is used only in
refractory seizures
such as Lennox
-Gassault syndrome.
Informed consent
is required. Why?
And a particular
class of drugs that
acts at presynaptic
site is used
for neuropathic pain,
a number of other
seizure uses, and
as add-on therapy
for management of
focal seizures.
What is its
mechanistic target?
So presynaptic
site, it's used
mainly for non
-seizure uses.
And think about
what its target is.
A broad-spectrum anti
-seizure drug with 100
% bioavailability, non
-hepatic metabolism,
renal excretion
of unchanged drug,
mild to moderate
side effects, and a
low potential for
drug interactions.
Broad spectrum.
And so what is the
drug? What is the
mechanistic target?
And what are the
most common side
effects of the narrow
-spectrum drug for
absence seizures?
So I'll uncover
the answers.
Felbamate is
associated with high
rates of fatal
aplastic anemia and
hepatic failure
compared with patients
taking other anti
-seizure drugs.
Gappapentanoids block
the alpha-2 delta
subunit of the voltage
-gated calcium channel
on presynaptic neurons,
which may decrease
the synaptic release
of excitatory
neurotransmitters.
The actual mechanism
is not known,
and in fact, this
has been theoretical.
There have been
many theories put
forward since the
drugs were developed.
And regarding the
broad-spectrum anti
-seizure drugs with
really excellent
pharmacokinetic profile
and low-potential and
mild-to-moderate side
effects, of course,
that's levotiracetam,
which blocks the
SV2A, which may prevent
docking of the vesicle
and release of the
neurotransmitter.
And the common side
effects of ethosuxamide,
nausea, vomiting,
somnolent, sleep disorder,
and hyperactivity.
And I put in here also
the CYP3A4-related
drug-drug interactions.
Now, moving to drugs
that enhance synaptic
GABA activity. These
are called GABA-A
receptor-positive
allosteric modulators.
And we're going to
be talking about
phenobarbital and
the benzodiazepines.
Here is the point
of the mechanism of
action. It's at
the postsynaptic
membrane, and you can
see the arrows are
pointing, both of
these arrows are
just pointing to
the GABA-A receptor.
So we'll begin
with phenobarbital.
I'm not going to
talk about primidone.
I'm just going to
mention a couple of
things about it
because it's board
relevant. It may come
up in a board exam.
so just for now
phenobarbital is the
one with the star on
it and here is the
phenobarbital i'm
just going to go down
the pharmacokinetics
of phenobarbital
for now and i'll
point out a couple
of things about
primidone so oral good
bioavailability iv
i am so variety of
methods to introduce
the drug to the patient.
IV onset of action
is fairly quick.
Protein binding
pretty high.
We need to be
remembering that
neonates and infants
who may be who are
patients who might be
receiving phenobarbital
have a different
volume of distribution.
They're basically
little bags of water. So
the neonatologist would
be careful with the
dosing of the drug and
recommendations are
in the monograph. We
see CYP2C9 involved
with the actual metabolism
of phenobarbital.
Phenobarbital is
a strong inducer
and you can see
this variety of CYPs
that are induced
by phenobarbital.
1A2, B6, C3A4,
UDP-glucuronaciltransferase,
and this
is not an enzyme,
of course, but
the efflux transporter
P-glycoprotein
is also induced
by phenobarbital.
Some of the drug
goes out unchanged,
and so renal dosing
is important.
long half-life look
at this one and a half
to five days in adults
it's still long in
infants and children
but probably not that
long one and a half
to five days in adults
takes a long time to
get to steady state
now primidone what
i want to point out
here is the metabolism
it is metabolized
to phenobarbital and
this active metabolite,
so that primidone,
phenobarotol,
and the active metabolite
are all active.
That's the sort
of thing that
might appear on
a board exam.
And it is oral only.
How does it work?
the barbiturates bind
to an allosteric site
on both alpha and beta
subunits of the GABA
ion channel and on
this figure we see
they're located within
the lipid bilayer high
doses this is so
important to remember high
doses also have a GABA
mimetic effect and
this means that even
in the absence of GABA,
barbiturates can
directly stimulate
the GABA-A receptors, and
this can lead to
coma and death.
The therapeutic uses for,
in terms of seizure uses,
focal onset,
generalized tonic-clonic
seizures in
children, and as an
alternative to
status epilepticus.
Alternative.
We'll see the first
line in a few moments.
the positive allosteric
modulators of GABA
-A receptor cause
sedation because GABA-A
activity is increased.
Oh, I forgot to mention.
Very important.
Barbiturates bind
to the allosteric
site and prolong
the duration,
prolong the duration
of the channel
opening. And since
the channel is opened
longer, more chloride
ion can flow through,
and that can cause
hyperpolarization,
and that's what GABA
receptors do, and
that can increase the
inhibitory effect.
I'm sorry, I had
to go backwards.
I forgot to mention
this before.
okay now we'll talk
about the adverse
effects so cns
depression basic global
cns depression sedation
mood depression
cognitive depression
hyperactivity in
children this is
again that hyper that
paradoxical effect
that we see with the
not always but sometimes
see in children
elderly folks
can also become
confused it makes sense
and something called
porphyrias i'm not
going to go into detail
on that at this point
but it's because the
barbiturates
induce the enzymes
Involved in heme
synthesis, heme metabolism,
and individuals
with porphyria have
deficiencies, and as
a result, porphyrins
can accumulate and
cause certain symptoms.
what else rash
naturally hepatotoxicity
bone marrow toxicity
these are well at
least bone marrow
toxicity is not as common
but we still have to
be watching for all of
these things now
intravenous we're sticking
drug into a vein
it's going in in high
concentrations barbiturates
are positive allosteric
modulators and also
GABA memetics so
respiratory depression is
a risk with phenobarbital
and especially when used
after benzodiazepine
i said before that
phenobarbital is an
alternative in the
treatment of status
epilepticus well
benzodiazepines are first line
and sometimes if that
if those seizures cannot
come under control
phenobarbital may be
administered after the
benzodiazepine so we
have to be thinking
about this respiratory
depression potential
and hypotension speaking
of benzodiazepines
i have just put
stars on three of
them i've listed out
all of them that
are used i i'm
going to briefly
mention them. I'm not
asking you to
memorize their names.
Well, let's see
if we can compare
some pharmacokinetics
here.
Well, a variety of
routes of administration,
onset diazepam, and
we're talking about
a single bolus dose,
bolus dose as is used
for status epilepticus
i'm not talking
about for non
-seizure uses here so
immediate with diazepam
a few minutes with
lorazepam and a few
minutes with midazolam
IM you can see takes
a little bit longer
Duration
Diazepam It's short I'll
get to the reason why
Lirazepam It's
good several
hours Midazolam
It's IV is still
One to two hours
Diazepam CYPs
are involved.
Midazolam, CYP is
involved, including
an active
metabolite. Diazepam
has an active
metabolite as well,
and that's called
nordiazepam.
Lorazepam, no CYPs.
and we see our
glucuronide
metabolites going
out in the urine
diazepam's actual half
-life in adults is long
40 hours an active
metabolite very long
three days or more
lorazepam also a long half
-life about a day and
midazolam is a much
shorter half-life by
comparison to the other
two these drugs are
going to keep coming up
over and over and
over they're very very
important drugs diazepam
accumulates with
multiple dosing and the
terminal half-life is
slightly prolonged as
the drug moves out of
fat stores so diazepam
is highly lipophilic
and it gets
stored in the fat.
The others do
too, but diazepam
is particularly
lipophilic.
Now, I said that
diazepam has a short
duration of
action, and that's
because of this
redistribution effect.
Rapid termination because
of redistribution.
Looking at this
figure here,
drug is administered
okay drug goes into
the blood right here this
is ivy administration
one dose one bolus
dose and it gets goes
into the uh blood and
it gets distributed
through the body and
one of the places it
goes to is the brain
highly perfused tissues
the brain has also
got a lot of fatty
tissue in it. So the
drug goes into the brain
tissue, causes its CNS
depressive effects.
One dose, remember.
And as the blood
levels keep dropping,
the levels in the CNS
will drop as the drug moves
down its concentration
gradient back into
the bloodstream.
And it will
be distributed
to the lean
tissue, muscle.
And it will be stored
in the muscle. And
it will be distributed
to the fat tissue.
And how much gets stored
in the fat depends
really on how long
that drug is on board.
But we're talking
about one bolus dose.
So that's redistribution.
It moves out
of the CNS. And as it
moves out of the CNS,
the effect is reduced.
It's terminated.
and it's not
leaving the body
it's just moving to other
tissues that's
all there is to it
a single bolus dose
of diazepam has a
short duration of anti
-seizure effect and
status epilepticus
about a quarter hour
to a half hour despite
its long half-life
mechanism
Oh, I put an arrow
here pointing to the
benzodiazepine that's
been indicated on this
figure by basic and
clinical pharmacology.
A positive
allosteric modulator
also, GABA-A receptor,
binds to allosteric
site as we can see.
It's not binding
to the active site
where GABA binds.
it increases the
frequency of channel
opening and as a
result a greater
concentration of chloride
will be introduced
into the cell.
So benzos is frequency,
barbiturates is duration.
The benzodiazepines do
not have GABA mimetic
activity. So if the
GABA goes, it gets
used up for some
reason because of high
activity, the benzos will
not continue upwards.
So if we were to look
at it on the chart,
barbiturates
look like this,
keep going, going, going,
whereas the benzos
will plateau.
But used together,
what are we worried
about? Respiratory
depression, high doses
of a benzo delivered
rapidly can also
increase the risk of
respiratory depression.
Now,
benzos are associated
with tolerance.
Tolerance can develop to
the anticonvulsive
effects.
It develops in weeks
to months, and as
a result, they're
not useful for the
chronic management of
nearly all seizures.
The one exception is
myoclonic seizures,
which I'll mention
in the next slide.
Benzos, status
epilepticus,
and also other
acute seizures.
so bolus dosing of
the benzos for the
initial treatment in
other words first line
diazepam immediate
onset and the
short duration
of action because
of that
redistribution effect
lorazepam takes a few
minutes but it has a
much longer anti-seizure
duration of action
midazolam is used if
an IV axis cannot be
obtained so it can be
given intramuscularly
intranasally it can be
given to be absorbed
through the buccal
mucosa so that's really
the place in therapy
of midazolam for its
anti-seizure uses now
chronic therapy these
are the drugs that
are used clonazepam
and chlorazepate they've
been around a long
time we see again the
Lennox-Gastaut syndrome
the myoclonic seizures
atonic seizures
usually used as add
-ons and clobasm is a
newer agent for the
Lennox-Gastaut syndrome
and other types of
treatment refractory
seizures as an add
-on now benzos have a
whole list of non
-seizure applications i'm
you'll be learning
about those as you
go along and as we
get to them we'll talk
about them the next
lecture is on anesthesia
and we'll be talking
about them again
oral ****** No
dosing, sedation,
depression, and
coordination. Some
of the usual
things that we see.
Acute hypotension,
ataxia, respiratory
depression. This
is due to the
rapid rise of the
drug in the CNS
concentrations. So the
idea is to introduce
it by slow
intravenous injection.
benzodiazepines that
are taken chronically
or even for the
management of status
epilepticus can produce
withdrawal seizures upon
discontinuation of the
drug so with status
epilepticus the benzo
will be given as
initial treatment and
then something else that
is has a much slower
onset and longer
duration of activity such
as phenytoin or valproic
acid or possibly even
levotiracetam would
be put on at the
same time in order to
manage the potential
for seizures later on.
Pregnancy.
Benzos, and now
we're really talking
about them when they're
used chronically
rather than just
that one or two doses
that would be used
for the acute seizure.
Hypoglycemia,
respiratory problems,
neonatal withdrawal,
and hypotonia.
This is called floppy
baby syndrome and
I've given you a
picture of it here.
So this is with
chronic use.
Our last one,
cannabidiol, the
mechanism is not known.
It does not appear
to act on cannabinoid
receptors.
It's taken ******
and it's got
really massive hepatic
metabolism, extensive
distribution.
Therapeutic uses
really for these
refractory seizures
associated with
Dravet syndrome, Lennox
-Gastaut syndrome,
this tuberous
sclerosis complex,
which is a terrible
seizure disorder.
Those are the indications
it's received
from the FDA.
Sedation, elevated
liver enzymes, high
potential for drug
interactions. Those
are the takeaways
with cannabidiol.
Oh,
I'll cover them
up quickly.
And what is the
mechanism of
action of the
GABA-A receptor
-positive allosteric
modulators?
What drugs fall
into this class?
What are the first
-line drugs for the
treatment of
status epilepticus?
When treating status
epilepticus, what
drug-drug combination
increases the
risk of respiratory
depression? What
is the explanation
for the short duration
of single-bolus
dose of diazepam?
And what are the anti
-seizure indications
of the pharmaceutical
cannabidiol?
So I'll uncover now.
The drugs bind an
allosteric side on the
GABA-A receptor and
enhance the receptor's
inhibitory action by
increasing chloride
ion influx. Of course,
we're talking about
the GABA-A receptor
-positive allosteric
modulators, the
barbiturates, and the benzos.
First-line drugs for
status epilepticus,
lorazepam, diazepam,
midazolam. Lorazepam
is used most
frequently. Diazepam
might also be used in
certain situations.
when treating status
epilepticus what
drug-drug combination
increases the risk
of respiratory
depression the benzo with
the phenobarbital
and why does diazepam
a single bolus
dose have a short
duration of action
because of the termination
of effect by
redistribution out of
the CNS into the
muscle and fat tissues
And what are
the indications
for pharmaceutical
cannabidiol,
the anti-seizure
indications,
Treves syndrome,
Lennox-Gasot syndrome,
and tuberous
sclerosis complex.
So I've given you
some figures here
of the various
molecular targets
of the drugs
and they've been
labeled by the
textbook illustrators.
And here are some
more. Just focus on the
ones we talked about.
But this gives you a
big picture that really
any kind of receptor
is fair game for blocking
the seizure activity,
excitatory synapse
activity. or
increasing the
inhibitory effect.
The question is,
are they effective?
If effective, how
tolerable are they?
I'm not going into
all of those details
in this lecture.
I've organized these by
seizure types, treatment,
and a summary of
the adverse effects.
hopefully these tables
will help you and
here are the resources
and that concludes
the lectures on the
anti-seizure drugs